c'était un moment de célébration pour
celle ci le network en octobre 2021 la
caisse de dépôt et placement du québec
annonçait avoir misé plus d'une centaine
de millions de dollars sur la compagnie
qui offre des services de prêt en crypto
monnaie csu se veut une solution de
rechange aux banques conventionnelles
comme dans un compte épargne les clients
peuvent y déposer leurs crypto menée et
obtenir un rendement sur leurs dépôts
ils peuvent aussi emprunter des crypto
monnaie
pour la cdpq ses partenaires
représentent l avenir du monde financier
la technologie des chaînes de blocs
présentent un potentiel perturbateur
pour plusieurs secteurs de l'économie
traditionnelle écrivait alors alexandre
sin est premier vice-président et chef
des technologies de la cdpq mais ce
potentiel perturbateur fait sourciller
plusieurs experts du domaine qui juge
que certaines activités de la compagnie
sont très risquées
ça se trouve
c'est
à 9 9 9 9
autrement dit les clients de celle-ci et
prennent le risque de tout perdre et
lors du krach de 11me ou 200 milliards
de dollars se sont évaporés du monde de
la crypto c'est exactement ce que
plusieurs utilisateurs de celsius disent
avoir vécu sur les réseaux sociaux il
écrivait que la crypto qu'ils avaient
déposées chez celsius pour obtenir des
prêts avaient été liquidés
la méthode celsius inquiète nos voisins
du sud dans la dernière année cinq états
américains ont envoyé des mises en garde
à l'entreprise la sommant de cesser des
activités jugées comme étant illégal
certains de ces avis précède
l'investissement de la cdpq
c'est sur ce conteste le bien fondé de
ces avis mais a cessé d'offrir aux
américains certains services en mars
2022 le département du travail des états
unis a publié un avis déconseillant
fortement aux fonds de retraite
américains
d'investir dans l'univers des crypto
monnaie au canada les autorités ont peu
à dire sur leur surveillance de ce
milieu pourtant le ministère fédéral des
finances nous confirme qu'en général ce
type d'entreprises non enregistrés agi
dans l'illégalité
c'est le cas de celsius qui offre ses
services financiers aux canadiens s'en
est inscrite auprès des autorités
financières du pays dans un courriel une
porte parole de la cdpq nous a écrit que
les investissements de la caisse font
l'objet d'un processus d'analysé
rigoureux elle ajoute que celle cieux
c'est favorable à la réglementation et
que la cdpq compte avoir une influence
positive sur ce processus le pdg de
celsis de son côté nous a écrit que la
société collabore avec les autorités
afin de rendre l'entreprise conforme aux
exigences des régulateurs de noël radio
canada montréal